[Music]
is there any organ in our body that can
float on water give it a shot if your
answer is that there is no oven in our
body that can float on water but you're
probably wrong because we have the
exception of lungs yes surprisingly the
only organ in the human body that can
float on water is the pair of lungs and
not only this but there are many other
interesting facts about lungs tell me
one thing is this organ that important
why our lungs so widely studied well
lungs form the core of the respiratory
system and this system makes sure that
we are alive and how is that done we've
seen how aquatic animals carry out the
vital gaseous exchange now it's time we
have a look at the respiratory system in
humans
this is how the complete respiratory
system looks like it begins from the
nose here and ends at the alveoli in the
lungs
let us get introduced to each part in
detail first comes the upper respiratory
tract it consists of the nasal cavity
the pharynx and the larynx let's
commence with studying the complete
nasal cavity if we zoom into the
structure we find that the nasal chamber
looks somewhat like this it mainly has
three regions or parts this is the part
we're all familiar with the nose any
idea what the openings are called as yes
they called as nostrils the nostrils
also called as Nerys are these openings
just as the nasal chamber within
commences we have the first region
called the vestibule this region bears
tiny hairlike structures which serve
different purposes any guesses what
functions the vestibule region will have
the region has a lining of mucous that
helps trap any foreign particle which
enters through the inhaled air also the
hair in this region expel the trapped
particles out with rhythmic movement so
the vestibule region has all the
arrangements to defend the bacteria or
other harmful particles let me try
entering the system with the inhaled air
the next region following this is the
respiratory region this region usually
serves many different functions most
importantly it warms the air to get it
to the normal body temperature then it
moistens it to make it suitable for the
body and lastly it helps send some air
to the third nasal chamber and push the
remaining air forward into the next part
of the respiratory tract
now what do you think that third chamber
would do with the air
well the name olfactory says it all the
region is responsible for the sense of
smell it contains highly sensitive cells
which send the received signal to the
brain and help in identifying the smell
post the nasal chamber comes the next
part called the pharynx this is like a
common connection between the
respiratory and the digestive tract and
why do we say so well as you can see
here this acts like a common passage
between the nasal chamber on the top and
the windpipe and the food pipe just
lying below it the pharynx is also
further divided into three parts the
nasal pharynx which is the continuation
with the nasal chamber oral pharynx the
one that lies behind the oral cavity
this is the central region and lastly we
have the laryngopharynx which is the
last region connecting to the next part
that is the larynx what do you think is
the pharynx important for well apart
from receiving food and air from the
respective zones the pharynx performs
one of the most crucial tasks
imagine what will happen even if a small
amount of food enters the respiratory
tract by mistake apart from the
discomfort caused it will be a serious
concern but how does the food know the
way to the food pipe each and every time
how doesn't the food accidentally enter
the windpipe well that's taken care of
by the pharynx do you notice a small
flap here this flap named the epiglottis
folds over to cover the surface below
when the food enters the system as a
result the opening of the windpipe gets
covered and the food strictly passes
into the esophagus the presence of the
epiglottis makes the pharynx an
extremely important part of the system
now next on the list is the larynx the
last part of the upper respiratory tract
is also known as the voice box now this
name talks about its significance it's
this responsible for creating the voice
that we have yes the larynx is involved
in the sound production and how does it
produce sound exactly well the voice box
has lateral folds somewhat like this now
imagine air to pass through these folds
when they are open
nothing really great can be noticed but
now when they are closed and when air
passes through them then the folds
vibrate and this gives rise to sound and
that's how the sound is produced by the
voice box the larynx is just a small box
like structure but in adults it just
produced slightly it becomes more
prominent in males after puberty and
this bulging structure in the throat is
called the Adam's apple well these three
components make up the upper respiratory
tract the nasal cavity the pharynx and
the larynx now let's have a glance at
the parts of the lower respiratory tract
in the next part
[Music]
you